hey guys the new celebration rules are  up yeah we can use the ball as a prop  yeah we could do group dances no way we  can dance on the ground but guys we  still can't do sex moves okay G men  clearly you need me to choreograph our  celebrations now let's show this league  how New York City does dance it really  screwed hold on maybe I should be the  leader because I'm correct yeah and  where do cortex go behind the linemen  but but can't see me back here trust me  it's for your protection and one and two  and McAdoo's step right lean back giant  step left and shimmy come on big blue  keep it high and tight nice Brandon  Eli stay in the pocket okay now get on  the Turnpike and hitchhike left now  hitchhike right come on flowers we need  you to get low bend those knees  okay now two-minute drill let's give  them that big Broadway finish with those  jazz hands let's see those jazz hands  jpp  [Music]